the sea was planted if excruciatingly
cold and a group of migrants took their
chance to cross this treacherous stretch
but their inflatable craft was badly
overloaded and it tipped in the middle
of the channel
[Music]
it's desperate passengers from a
multitude of Nations thrown into the
frigid sea
these pictures were taken from the side
of a fishing vessel here hauling in
human beings but the voices of those
stranded at Sea are clearly Audible
it was like something from a war movie
said the skipper there were people in
the water screaming everywhere
Royal and French navies and Regional
lifeboats came to their aid an
imperceptible Voyage now an
international incident
but their personnel struggled to extract
them from the sea
three were rescued but at least four
have died one between the rubbery
remains of the migrants inflatable
it took two hours to drag the survivors
from the sea each one drenched with
ill-fitting life jackets
they told the fishing boat crew they'd
paid five thousand pounds each for the
Crossing
a traumatic end for men who've journeyed
from Senegal and India from Afghanistan
and Iraq
this tragedy comes as the Prime Minister
implements new measures designed to Halt
the flow of migrants but it will be
difficult to stop those who are
determined to better their lives John
Sparks Sky News